[Music]
this is
so far quick
go yourself go get yourself on quick
can you light that up there on that side
keep it lit up keep it
we'll start
please
behind you here
Plus
get that thing really close to your
mouth and speak super loud dude
Metropolitan Police Department
Police Department we have a search
warranty
you to come out with your hand with your
hands up when your hands it's just it's
going inside
[Music]
[Applause]
as well
I need you to I need you to put your
shoes on put shoes
traffic
[Music]
Metropolitan Police Department
Austin
Rogers
yeah here comes the garage is up
that other car is blocked in
okay
okay do you need to stop right there
stop right there go ahead and put down
your cigarette please
put your hands up
keep your hands up down
sir you put your phone down put your
phone down put your hands on top of your
head hands on top of your head right now
we're gonna take that mail first okay
sir now go ahead and turn away from us
turn away from us
you're gonna walk back to the sound of
my voice
he's walking back
keep walking back take a step to your
left step through left okay hey face
away from me face the house slowly walk
back towards the sound of my voice
you're doing good I appreciate your
cooperation keep coming keep coming keep
coming keep coming keep coming
what's your name
hi what's your name sir
okay
for me please thank you
everybody
just looking for me is there anybody
else except me or my wife
you need dogs
spread your feet for me partner spread
your feet from your partner thank you
yeah stop talking on the phone
why so Smith right yeah
all right we're ready for the female
let's go ahead and bring her down
okay all right
you're right
okay now go ahead and turn away from us
now walk back to the sound of my voice
Nate have her turn around and just face
us and walk off
and walk straight forward
so you can see where you're going
all right ma'am I need you to come right
to my voice please just keep coming
you're doing great
appreciate your cooperation just keep
walking right back over here please keep
walking keep walking keep walking step
out come on keep coming come on you're
fine you're fine over here please
well we're just getting everybody that's
inside the house come over here please
right here you're fine right here for
just a second
for sure
you put this hand on top of your head
for me for a second please
do me a favor
okay
oh they're gonna get you out of them why
would you do me like this I've been
doing too tight I appreciate your
cooperation in a second I'm going to
pass you off to the defections they will
take you out of these cups
they are pretty loose
who else is inside nobody no kids no no
dogs no no
but okay
are you going to turn my house up
man we are going to go in and search
your house so if there is anybody else
in there nobody okay
okay
Hey where's the
[Music]
joke where's the shield in the 40 I
don't know
okay it's just me and you dude hold that
right now
you got a multi launcher if you want it
sure
yeah bro
thanks pal
nobody else is inside
I got wild
hey Nate let's get back on the PA please
[Applause]
empty
occupation of 2204 Maple Shade this is
the Lost Invasion Metropolitan Police
Department we have a search warrant for
the residents to come out with your
hands up your hands champions
directions
Metropolitan Police Department
[Music]
Police Department
copy that
you guys
let's pack up that Recon Scout
s
[Applause]
your hands
all right
can you bring that up
Carrie bring up the ram
s
you got the other Shield I got it
the last
days
do it now
Las Vegas Metropolitan Police Department
for the residence
you come out of the house
two two zero four Maple Shade
it's the Las Vegas Metropolitan Police
Department
Police Department
you need to come out of the house do it
do it now
hi sorry to bug we're all done back
there I'm sorry for the inconvenience
though okay we appreciate your
cooperation all right thank you ma'am
have a good night now bye-bye say that
again okay okay all right bye-bye